El día 7 de agosto del 2018, Iván Duque
Márquez juró el cargo como presidente de
Colombia con una promesa: poner en forma al
país y prepararlo para un proceso de desarrollo
rápido.
Amigos, desde entonces, desde la investidura
de Iván Duque, ha pasado el tiempo suficiente
como para que aquí en VisualPolitik nos hagamos
algunas preguntas:
¿Cuál es realmente el programa político
del gobierno de Duque?
Es decir, ¿Cómo quiere transformar Colombia?
¿Puede llegar a conseguirlo?
¿Qué puede suponer su paso por la Casa Nariño
- la Casa Blanca colombiana?
Atentos.
Con casi 50 millones de habitantes, Colombia
es el segundo país más poblado de América
del Sur.
Pero sobre todo es un país complicado, muy
complicado:
Fijaos, por un lado está el problema de las
guerrillas y el narcotráfico, una de las
mayores industrias del país.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Colombia produce
ni más ni menos que el 70% de todos los polvos
blancos que se fabrican en el planeta.
¡El 70%!
Por supuesto, tal y como os podéis imaginar,
detrás de todo este inmenso negocio que cada
año mueve miles y miles de millones de dólares
se encuentran poderosas organizaciones criminales.
Organizaciones dispuestas a controlar su territorio
contra viento y marea.
Eso es, precisamente, lo que explica que las
tasas de violencia siguen siendo muy altas.
(Colombia: homicidios aumentaron en 2018 por
violencia tras desarme de las FARC
Según la autoridad forense del país, hubo
12.130 homicidios el año pasado, un 6,7 % más
que en 2017.)
Y no solo eso, tan solo en los últimos tres
años se calcula que más de 500 activistas
y líderes comunitarios han perdido la vida
a manos de estos grupos; y cerca de 200.000
personas se han visto desplazadas de sus hogares.
Y aquí no termina todo.
Además, el ELN, un grupo guerrillero de extrema
izquierda - vinculado también al
narcotráfico - continúa operando;
(21/01/2019 La guerrilla del ELN reivindica
el atentado contra la academia de policía
que causó más de 20 muertos.)
También, cerca de 3.000 antiguos miembros
de las FARC podrían haber retomado las armas;
y las plantaciones de Coca están en máximos
históricos.
(Los cultivos de coca en Colombia alcanzaron
un máximo histórico en 2017
con 171.000 hectáreas.)
(Luego, por si todos estos problemas no fueran
suficiente, durante los últimos años Colombia
se ha enfrentado a la llegada de cientos y
cientos de miles de venezolanos huyendo del
despótico régimen de Nicolás Maduros.
Se calcula que ya hay aproximadamente un millón
y medio de venezolanos viviendo en Colombia.)
Lo que está muy bien.
[De verdad, desde aquí, a todos los colombianos:
Enhorabuena por semejante muestra de solidaridad.]
El problema es que todo esto también supone
una enorme presión sobre la estabilidad y
los recursos públicos.
Pero… Vale, esta es, digamos, la peor cara.
Pero Colombia también tiene otra cara.
Veréis, a pesar de todos los problemas, como
el narco, las guerrillas, los grupos paramilitares,
la violencia, la corrupción… Lo cierto
es que durante los últimos 40 años el país
ha registrado un crecimiento económico medio
del 3,8% anual; la clase media ha crecido
y el país no ha sufrido ninguna hiperinflación.
[Ojo, no te pienses que eso es normal.
No te olvides que estamos hablando hablando
de América del Sur.
Durante ese mismo periodo de tiempo Perú,
Bolivia, Argentina, Ecuador Brasil y Venezuela
sí que han experimentado procesos de hiperinflación.]
En otras palabras, que casi podríamos decir
que Colombia es un modelo de estabilidad.
Sin embargo, amigos, esperad un momento, porque
el propio presidente colombiano, Iván Duque
no está del todo de acuerdo.
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Un 5% es la meta que se ha fijado el presidente
colombiano.
Ahora bien, ¿Será capaz de lograrlo?
¿Cómo quiere lograrlo?
Con el panorama que hemos descrito parece
complicado, ¿No os parece?
Pues, ¿sabéis qué?
No podemos decir si lo va a lograr o no, pero
lo cierto es que este gobierno tiene un plan
- lo que visto lo visto no resulta tan frecuente,
¿verdad Presidente Macri?.
Un plan que la verdad no tiene mala pinta
y que podemos sintetizar en tres puntos principales.
Atentos.
(HUYENDO DE LA FISCALIDAD LATINOAMERICANA)
Amigos, puede que esto os resulte sorprendente,
pero en general los sistemas fiscales de los
países latinoamericanos tienen una característica
común:
Tienen los impuestos a las empresas más altos
de todo el planeta.
¿Queréis algún ejemplo?
Atentos.
Veréis, la incapacidad de los gobiernos para
recaudar dinero de las personas físicas,
de las personas de carne y hueso ha hecho
que concentren su voracidad tributaria sobre
el sistema productivo.
[Es todo lo contrario de lo que, por ejemplo,
hacen los países nórdicos, de los que tanto
se habla.]
Y, ojo, porque si por lo general en Latinoamérica
la cosa está mal, en Colombia es mucho pero
que mucho peor.
Pero vale, seguro que alguno de vosotros se
está preguntando, pero Alberto, ¿Cuanto
peor?
¿1 punto, 2 puntos?
Pues no nada de eso.
(Para que os hagáis una idea según el último
informe Doing Business del Banco Mundial,
la tasa de tributación efectiva de las empresas
colombianas, es decir si tenemos en cuenta
todos los impuestos que se cargan sobre una
empresa: locales, nacionales, laborales, corporativos...
Entonces resulta que las empresas colombianas
se enfrentan a un tipo medio del 71,9%.)
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
El 71,9% del beneficio comercial de las empresas,
es decir de la diferencia entre ingresos y
gastos sin tener en cuenta los impuestos,
va directamente al bolsillo de las Administraciones
Públicas.
Para que os hagáis una idea cuando una empresa
colombiana compraba una máquina no podía
deducirse completamente el IVA o incluso existían
impuestos que las empresas tenían que pagar
aunque tuvieran pérdidas.
¡De locos!
Y evidentemente todo esto es algo que tiene
consecuencias:
Unos impuestos tan altos sobre el tejido productivo
afectan a la competitividad de la economía
colombiana.
Y a todo esto le tenemos que añadir la cansina,
agotadora y pesada burocracia típica de los
países latinoamericanas.
Seguro que ahora entendeis porque los países
latinoamericanos tienen por lo general bajos
nivel niveles de inversión, bajos niveles
de exportaciones y mucha, muchísima economía
informal.
(05/2017: La economía informal de América
Latina supera por primera vez la de África
Subsahariana.)
De hecho, se estima que más del 54% de las
empresas colombianas no están correctamente
formalizadas.
Y claro, una empresa informal pues no puede
acceder a grandes contratos, ni a financiación
bancaria ni disfrutar de tanta seguridad jurídica.
Vamos que no crecen ni para atrás.
Pues bien, precisamente enfrentarse a esta
situación es el primer gran punto del Plan
de Ivan Duque.
De hecho, a finales del año pasado logró
que el Congreso de la República aprobase
una amplia reforma fiscal.
Su reforma fiscal.
(Básicamente la reforma ha consistido en
reducir la tributación a las empresas colombianas
incrementando ligeramente los impuestos a
las rentas más altas, por ejemplo a las personas
que cobran más de 120.000 dólares y que
hoy pagan pocos impuestos.
Y también incrementando la recaudación por
IVA.
De esta forma con la nueva reforma el impuesto
sobre beneficios se reducirá progresivamente
del 33 al 30%; desaparecerán algunos impuestos
adicionales y se crea un sistema simplificado
con un único impuesto con tipos muy reducidos
para alentar la formalización y el crecimiento
de las pequeñas empresas.)
Y eso no es todo.
Además, la reforma también ha creado incentivos
fiscales para los emprendedores, para la inversiones
en grandes proyectos y para las inversiones
en el sector turístico o en la llamada economía
naranja.
Y sí, vale, estoy puede resultar más controvertido,
al fin y al cabo, ¿Por qué unos sectores
sí y otros no?
Pero bueno, al menos parece ir en la buena
dirección, ¿no os parece?
(La cuestión, y tal vez es lo que ha hecho
que este proyecto resulte tan polémico es
que como Duque va incrementar notablemente
el gasto público y además el gobierno tiene
un elevado déficit público, aunque la medida
supone una reducción de impuestos a medio
plazo a corto plazo implica subirlos.)
Es decir, mientras las reducciones son progresivas,
las subidas se van a aplicar desde el principio.
Por ejemplo, un recargo temporal sobre los
beneficios de los bancos.
Y eso no ha gustado nada.
Y sí, Presidente Duque usted dijo que iba a bajar
los impuestos, no que los iba a subir.
Y los está subiendo, así que tampoco puede
resultar extrañas algunas críticas.
Pero aún así - y ojo ya sabéis que en VisualPolitik
no nos gustan nada las subidas de impuestos
- pensamos que el cambio va en la buena dirección.
Latinoamérica en general y Colombia en particular
tienen que tratar mejor a los sectores productivos.
Latinoamérica necesita más empresas no más
impuestos.
(LA ECONOMÍA NARANJA)
El segundo punto clave en la estrategia de
Iván Duque es promover con incentivos fiscales,
con préstamos participativos, con capital
riesgo y con aceleradoras de startups, la
llamada economía naranja.
Ahora bien, un momento.
¿Qué demonios es eso de la
economía naranja?
Pues no, no tiene nada que ver con las naranjas
- con la fruta - sino que así es como se
conoce a las actividades creativas vinculadas
con la propiedad intelectual: música, diseño,
producciones audiovisuales, canales de YouTube,
arquitectura, diseño de software arte, etcétera,
Mirad, ¿Os habéis dado cuenta que cada vez
hay más películas y series rodadas en Colombia?
Incluso cada vez hay más producciones de
plataformas como Netflix o Amazon Prime que
se realizan en este país.
Y todo esto tiene una explicación.
(En 2012 se aprobó la ley 1556 que contemplaba
importantes incentivos fiscales y ayudas a
la producción de películas y rodajes cinematográficos
en Colombia.
Se buscaba de esa forma no solo hacer crecer
la industria nacional del cine sino también
favorecer una imagen mejor del país en el
mundo.
El resultado es que el número de producciones
en Colombia se disparó)
Pues bien, ahora Iván Duque quiere hacer
lo mismo con todas las actividades que quedan
dentro de esta “economía naranja”.
Y ojo porque no es ninguna tontería.
A día de hoy la economía naranja en Colombia
es casi tres veces más grande que la industria
del café y casi tan grande como todo el sector
de la minería.
Hablamos de actividades económicas cuyo comercio
a nivel mundial crece a ritmos del 7% anual
y cuyo valor en 2015 ya superaba los 500 mil
millones de dólares.
(“La economía naranja es mucho más que
el nuevo petróleo.
Las reservas de petróleo son limitadas pero
la creatividad es ilimitada.
Tenemos que ser conscientes que el patrimonio
más importante que tenemos en una sociedad
es el talento de su gente”.
Ivan Duque)
Pues bien, para lograr este propósito el
gobierno está poniendo en marcha planes de
financiación participativa, iniciativas de
capital riesgo, centros de emprendimiento
y exenciones fiscales.
¿Funcionara?
¿Tendrá realmente la economía naranja la
capacidad de transformar Colombia?
Sólo el tiempo podrá decirlo, pero, ¿sabéis
qué?
Es un plan que suena bien.
Y al menos es un plan diferente y ligado al
capital humano y no a los recursos naturales
ni a las grandes empresas cercanas a los gobiernos,
que por desgracia suele ser lo habitual en
Latinoamérica.
Pero aquí no termina todo.
Aún nos queda otro pilar esencial en toda
esta estrategia.
(LAS NUEVAS APUESTAS)
No es estrictamente una idea de Iván Duque,
pero parece que el nuevo gobierno la ha comprado.
Colombia quiere convertirse en el gran jugador
en el mercado mundial del Cannabis medicinal.
Un sector que crece como la espuma y que se
espera se convierta en un mercado de casi
50 mil millones para el año 2025.
Y, amigos, Colombia aspira a tener una cuota
de más del 40%.
Es decir, hablamos de un sector enorme y todo
un empujón para la economía colombiana,
especialmente para la economía de las zonas
rurales más pobres.
("Nos llama a la posibilidad de ser jugadores
muy importantes a nivel mundial en materia
de exportaciones, las estimaciones hablan
de que efectivamente podríamos estar en niveles
de US$6.000 millones de dólares anuales de
exportación".
Saúl Pineda, Viceministro de Desarrollo Empresarial)
Pues bien, junto a las puntiagudas plantas
verdes, la otra gran apuesta del gobierno
pasa por impulsar el Fracking para incrementar
la producción petrolera.
De momento ya se han aprobado cuatro proyectos
pilotos que podrían producir más de 400
mil barriles diarios cuando estén plenamente
operativos.
Esto supondría incrementar la producción
de petróleo de Colombia en casi un 50%.
En fin con todas estas medidas y con una mayor
inversión en infraestructuras y en educación
es como el gobierno de Ivan Duque quiere conseguir
su objetivo de elevar el crecimiento económico
de Colombia por encima del 5%.
¿Lo conseguirá?
En VisualPolitik estaremos muy atentos, pero
las cosas como son.
No pinta mal.
Por supuesto hay otras cuestiones por resolver
y que pueden generar muchos problemas: por
ejemplo, el fuerte incremento del gasto público
o la constante devaluación del peso colombiano.
Y desde luego el gobierno de Duque no se ha
limitado a tomar medidas solo en el campo
económico.
¿Qué pasa con los narcos?
¿Qué hacer con la seguridad?
¿Qué está haciendo en política exterior?
Pues amigos, de todo eso hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik, así
que no olvideis suscribiros.
Y Ahora, si os parece, espero vuestros comentarios
para que nos contéis qué opinión tenéis
de Duque y de los cambios que está impulsando.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima